[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина,
Добропілля]
У місті одна із проблем у тому,
що дітям до 18 років, молоді — їм є де займатися.
Є різні позашкільні заклади.
А після 18 років — абсолютно нічим займатися.
[Володимир Орос
Соціальний підприємець]
У 2010 році ми створили громадську організацію
«Добропільський центр молоді “Добро ”».
Ціллю цієї організації було саме
створення молодіжного центру.
Потім об'єдналися декілька
громадських організацій
і спільно досягнули того,
що нам виділили приміщення.
Почав займатися, бо з'явилося
більше інформації в інтернеті.
Різні ресурси стали більш доступними.
З'явилося більше знань.
З'їздив на декілька тренінгів, зацікавився.
Є можливість не приходити до міської влади,
мовляв, дайте грошей —
а навпаки, залучити у місто додаткові кошти,
на які вже реалізовувати
якісь соціальні проєкти.
Ми проводили і музичний фестиваль,
і різноманітні спортивні заходи.
Тобто все, в чому зацікавлена молодь.
Збирається ініціативна група у якомусь напрямі,
ми шукаємо на це фінансування і просуваємо.
Ми розташовані у такому специфічному місці:
за будинками, нас з дороги не видно.
[Ірина Козачук
Бібліотекарка]
Тому це таке місце для тих, хто знає.
О, наші користувачі!
Це відвідувачі інтернет-центру.
Бібліотека така, яка вона має бути — з книгами.
Але ми вже більше на шлях
таких перетворень стали.
Бібліотека — це простір, це публічний простір,
місце для зустрічі людей.
Я — бібліотекар за професією і за покликанням.
У бібліотеках відбувається
дуже багато цікавих заходів,
різних проєктів.
У центральній бібліотеці зараз
такий цікавий проєкт відбувається:
анімація для людей з інвалідністю.
Це проєкт інтеграції цих людей у суспільство.
Насамперед вони навчаються
спілкуватися між собою.
Ще одну ініціативу ми запустили
в цій бібліотеці.
Це Green Art — текстильна майстерня.
Ми, разом з нашими відвідувачами,
на одній-єдиній швейній машинці
виготовляємо екоторбу.
Шопер — це екологічна сумка,
зроблена своїми руками.
Краща, ніж куплена.
І ми свідомо відмовляємося
від поліетиленового пакета.
Звісно, ми не розв'язуємо екологічну проблему
в глобальному її розумінні.
Крок за кроком, кожен починає зі себе —
робимо те, що можемо.
Якщо хочеш, щоб щось було у твоєму місті —
потрібно зробити це самому.
Брати відповідальність, якісь проєкти.
[Владислав Бурховецький
Громадський активіст]
Бо навіть якщо хтось інший зробить —
це може тобі не подобатись.
Ти все одно не будеш задоволений.
А коли в людей є якісь ідеї,
і ти даєш їм підтримку,
можливість десь залучити фінанси,
чи домовитися з владою.
Людей це лякає — «як?», «куди піти?».
А коли ти бачиш класні ініціативи, що йдуть знизу,
і коли люди бачать, що це втілюється —
тоді з'являється власна відповідальність
та почуття належності до міста.
Що так, я тут живу, це моє місце.
І вже не просто почуття як до дитячого
майданчика чи якогось об'єкта,
а з'являються зовсім інші почуття.
Ось саме це ми зробили,
коли був конкурс мінігрантів.
І ми допомогли хлопцям,
які займались волейболом — на асфальті,
тобто це і травми, і речі псуються.
Ми допомогли їм написати проєктну заявку.
Там була сума всього 15 тисяч гривень.
І ось ми купили опори, розмітку,
м'яч, сітку.
Потім ми з міською владою домовилися,
щоб вони нам виділили тут місце.
Місто нам виділило близько 150 тонн піску.
І близько 40 тонн щебеню.
Тобто тут приблизно півметровий котлован.
Технікою вони допомогли,
спиляли декілька старих дерев.
Все це волонтери — молодь,
людей 30 — лопатами розкидали.
Зокрема лавки, ми їх теж своїми руками робили.
У нас молодіжна організація «Творці історії»
і разом ми формуємо успішний
та здоровий спосіб життя.
І коли такі ініціативи йдуть знизу —
ми стараємося їх підтримувати
та реалізувати.
Ми з усіма активістами вирішили,
що це промислове місто і тут дві шахти,
навколо яких все будується.
Усе таке сіре, сире, а у нас був екозапит.
Не дитячі майданчики — металеві, червоні,
а все у екостилі, в стилі дерева.
Щоб допомагати формувати це у людей.
Бо ми розуміємо, що одного разу
шахти закриються,
але місто повинне бути цікавим.
І мислення в людей повинне формуватися інше.
Щоб були місця, які можна показати.
Не так, щоб як палаци культури,
які раніше всі однакові робили.
Ось це, що ми самі придумали і  з дизайнерами
та архітекторами спроєктували —
тут будуть основи, вже стовбці залиті.
Це амфітеатр — буде повністю дерев'яний майданчик.
З такими рядами.
Буде прозорий дах.
Також будуть якісь вуличні меблі.
Там ми зможемо дивитися фільми
і проводити якісь творчі вечори.
Ми назвали це «Сквер 21».
Бо ми тут хочемо провести 21 ініціативу.
У нас тут теж є клуб друзів.
Ось хто тут буде доглядати,
хто бере участь, щось робить.
І ми думатимемо далі,
як його тут оживляти.
А після 21 заходу далі ми самостійно проводитимемо всі наші заходи,
активності, які ми проводимо у приміщенні
чи у молодіжному центрі, ну там мало місця.
Припустимо, творчий вечір, запросити музикантів,
вже хочеться на свіжому повітрі влітку.
У людей є цей запит на щось нове.
Щоб сюди люди приїжджали, залишались.
Якщо зараз місто перевтілюється,
мабуть, раніше, воно таким не було.
Тобто тут особливо не було чим зайнятися.
Це зараз ми вже про це не задумуємось,
що немає чим зайнятись, бо вже є чим.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Tik Tu]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]